[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our president is about a thousand years
old the birth rate has fallen to the
lowest level
ever after having been below replacement
for 50 years
people are getting married at the lowest
rates ever recorded
and we kill a million babies a year
through abortion
we are living in a culture of death
if a conservative said that 30 years ago
40 years ago people would have written
him off as a kook
as a as a hyperbolist as some kind of
radical now it seems undeniable
how do we get out of it i am joined
right now
by my dear friend one of the great
pro-life
activists ever you know not not even
just right now but but in the history of
the country
lila rose lila rose the head of live
action
and the author of fighting for life
becoming a force
for change in a wounded world lila
thank you for coming on thanks for
having me michael
so lila after that cheery introduction
uh how do we fix it how do we get out of
it
well it's funny i end fighting for life
the book that's this guidebook for
activists or change makers and i end it
saying
you know have families um embrace family
life embrace marriage embrace kids and
if you don't
feel called to that yourself support
other people who are
because ultimately the change is made in
our own families and how we commit to
love and commit to responsibility that's
really the deeper cultural change that's
necessary the reason we have all these
political excesses and
the most pro-abortion administration in
our history i mean even worse than under
obama joe biden
stepped into the an even more
radicalized version of himself when he
partnered with kamala harris who's going
after
you know our friends david deliden and
sandra merritt in california when she
was attorney general to try to prosecute
pro-life journalists in despite all of
that what's the end game for i think
not just conservatives but people of
conviction and truth people who care
about the future of this country
it's really rebuilding in our
communities and that primarily through
the family
yes oh i'm on my second kid i know we're
expecting number two and i know
i know that you're married michael and
that's the whole daily wire thing is the
family and
promoting families and that that's
really the future i think it is you can
see the effect of my first child on my
under eye bags you can see that that has
really deepened and we i can't wait for
number two and then i want to have three
four five and six
i want an army of little michaels to
spread around this country
uh but but a lot of people are not doing
that and i think a lot of
you see it reflected in in the data a
lot of
millennials in particular are just
putting off getting married
and they'll cohabitate and they'll have
long relationships
they're putting off having kids they'll
get a little puppy that they drag around
on a thousand dollar stroller
but they they don't want to have babies
and
you know i say this from some personal
experience i
like you lila i'm a mackerel snapping
papist and catholic
and uh so i expected to have a kid nine
months after my wedding day
and it didn't happen you know it
actually sometimes it takes a little
while and
so it you know i i it's just so
so sad to me that there are some people
who can't have kids
there's some people for whom having kids
is a very difficult thing
and there are some people who can do it
and they just
throw it away they describe uh
having children is basically as a
venereal disease they describe the
problem of
overpopulation you notice the people who
talk about overpopulation
never want to take themselves out of the
population they always want to take
somebody else
out of the population so how do we how
do we push back against
uh that that movement that seems to have
so much momentum
well it's funny because i mean even
british vogue there was a couple that
article a few weeks ago saying it's
having children environmental terrorism
and there is this push that's saying
having children is a bad thing and there
are you know economic struggles and all
sorts of concerns that millennials have
about kids which i think are important
to discuss and explore but
what i did in fighting for life as i
walked through how did we get here i
mean it's both the story of live action
and starting at age 15 and building it
into this global pro-life movement
but it's also how did we get to the
point as you described where there were
nearly a million abortions a year
and why do we have this negative
attitude about kids and
what i explore and what i think is so uh
incredibly important to talk about
michael which i know you've discussed
before but it needs to be talked about
more
is it really goes back to two things
number one
something called the sexual revolution
in our country
where we divorced we separated sex
from children and marriage so now sex is
about one thing only consent basically
don't
rape other morality today around sex
don't rape
have fun if you can whatever you want to
do as long as it's two adults you're
good to go
and that's not the way sex works i mean
sex can create new life
sex bonds people together very
powerfully um emotionally and
spiritually i believe
and it's not something that is just
about moments of pleasure it's about a
relationship ultimately
and there's a reason i mean i discussed
in fighting for life how
even planned parenthood admit means the
biggest abortion chain
and the guttmacher institute is their
research arm and guttmacher institute
admits the pro-abortion people admit
that 50 of the women who have abortions
today
in in our country and that's 2300
abortions a day
50 of those women were using
contraception
in the month that they got pregnant with
this unplanned pregnancy
50 so this idea that contraception
safe sex will protect against abortion
is a myth and a lie and it's one of the
reasons we have so much abortion
because people societally we expect that
sex
is without responsibility and that
really is part of the solution is
changing our mindset
on relationships changing our mindset on
sex and
and encouraging younger people i mean i
think the message that
abortion is the solution if you get
pregnant but you should just have sex
freely you know it's not sex is not
about love and responsibility is a
completely backwards message
instead of saying celebrate children no
matter how they're conceived
and sex is actually precious and
involves responsibility that's the
message we should be sending people so i
think that's part of the change that's
needed
that cultural educational shift for our
country to have
right and i love this this focus on
consent
i think you're totally right consent has
now become
the only thing that matters whatsoever
when you're talking about sex
however you'll notice that that
when sexual matters go awry when the
sexual revolution leads to bad
consequences
the left needs to put this in the
language of consent
so what they'll say is well yes this
looked like a totally consensual sexual
act but
actually the woman was drunk and now the
man was probably drunk too but they'll
say well if you're drunk you can't give
consent which means that
basically any sexual union between
single people under the age of 30
is de facto rape mutual rape right
because most people are having a couple
of cocktails before
they make these sorts of decisions okay
now let's say that
alcohol is not involved or drugs or any
sort of impairment you've seen this now
with some allegations against rock stars
like marilyn manson
where a woman will say look i was in an
ostensibly
consensual relationship and no we
weren't drinking a lot or using drugs or
anything
but it was still it still wasn't really
consent because
he manipulated me he groomed me when i
was 20.
he he uh
[Music]
just i don't know he warped my mind into
consenting to things that i've now come
to regret
and it seems to me what they're
grappling with is the fact that
as as you described very well these
virtues are habits you know you've got
to the more you practice
virtues the easier they become and vices
is a sort of habit too
and when we engage in vice and sin we
compromise our free will and
you know so that the heroin addict is a
heroin addict and all he wants to do is
shoot up heroin
he can't consent anymore even even when
he's sober he can't consent
because he has this vicious desire so
i'm so with you i really wish
we would take the conversation beyond
these you know
shallower talking points into another
area but but how do we do it
you know so much of your work is focused
on
abortion this is you know one of if not
the greatest scourge in the country
but the pro-life issue is about more
than that the the culture of life would
be
about even more than the issue of
abortion right it's about
um ultimately who we are individually
and how we love others
i mean that sounds so fundamental but it
is the truth it's about
how we see the dignity of every single
person we encounter and so
a lot of my book fighting for life is
about just that it's not just the story
of
me starting this organization at 15 and
how you get started as an activist or
you know how you if you're a young mom
at a school and you want to get involved
in the school board or
if you're a student or whatever you are
how you get involved in the pro-life
fight or really any cause
but it's also this journey of personal
transformation a journey that i'm still
on which i think is the ultimate
solution to
the the crises today i mean how do you
solve the problem of abortion
well it goes back to a problem of
personal relationship
and really how we see ourselves in our
own sexuality right just this cheapening
of sex as you were describing
um addictions around sex and dysfunction
around sex
and where does that come from that comes
from a misunderstanding of
who we are as people and what love is um
of what really we should be aiming for
in life what makes us happy
does short-term sexual pleasure make us
happy that leads to an unplanned
pregnancy and then we go have an
abortion does that make you happy no
statistically
women who have abortions are up to 100
times more likely
to commit 100 more likely to commit
suicide in the following year
because of the trauma of that decision
so we know that these things actually
don't bring happiness i mean mental
health crises are
sky high right now every year addiction
increases
pornography use increases mental health
anxiety depression increased suicide
rate increased
so whatever we're doing around how we
treat our bodies
and how we relate to other people the
abortion rate
it's not working and so my biggest
solution in the book and i share these
27 principles and some of them for me
are first of all knowing your worth
this is a really important message if
there are young women listening or you
have young women in your life
knowing your value as a woman respecting
yourself as a woman
um or as a man i mean as a human being
um made in the image and likeness of god
i mean that's a
an idea that we're endowed by our
creators in our declaration of
independence right it's not just a
um a religious belief per se that you
have to subscribe to the entire religion
but it's actually fundamental for how
our whole legal system is built our
whole idea of human right
come from a god who gave them to us and
it's this idea that we have these
we're like god our human nature we have
the ability to love to choose
and that's why we have rights that
should protect certain freedoms of how
we are
how we operate how we want to live our
lives and so if we can
know our value um and respect the value
of other people
then we have higher standards we have
higher standards for our dating
relationships we're not going to go
sleep with marilyn manson as you were
talking about earlier michael i mean
the women are now saying you know he it
wasn't consent consensual whatever i
mean we're going to have higher
standards for who
and how we love um for what our life is
about i also talk about
the importance of um for those that are
still wrestling with faith or don't have
a faith letting god find us
so i should actually share my faith
journey because i do think that's very
important
um you know i respect anybody where they
are in their journey with god
or what they believe on that but i share
how really understanding
you know what are we aiming toward um is
there a god in our life
everybody has some sort of religion we
hold to whether we realize it or not
what is yours you know is it based on
absolute truth is it based on
a god who is loving or is it based on
you know this idea of science maybe
science is your god or
maybe you're your own god you decide
morality you're kind of the end-all
be-all
um but who we put our admiration in
what we put our trust in really affects
who we are too
and i talk about the power of heroes you
know if you're gonna make a difference
in the world
if you're gonna stand up in these
cultural or political battles
knowing who your heroes are your your
models are
and having good one is so powerful and
important so these are some of the
principles i share but i think
that is actually key to building the
culture of life is
ourselves allowing ourselves to be
changed as much as we want to change the
world around us
certainly a culture is defined by what
it worships cult and culture come from
the same root word
and uh you know where where you put your
time where you put your focus where you
put your money that that is
that is what you're going to worship now
what you're saying
is that the culture of life is coherent
and it has integrity
if you have the cul if you respect a
culture of life over here it's going to
express itself over there and over there
and over there
if you have respect for the human person
and you're dealing this every day with
people then you're going to have respect
for unborn babies then you're gonna have
respect
for this person and that person okay for
people who are
older for instance you're gonna oppose
assisted suicide okay
but the left and i use that term
specifically
because i'm not you know they might have
different views on certain issues
but they consider themselves on the left
they'll come in and say okay
you crazy pro-lifers you want less
abortion
the way to get less abortion is not to
have a coherent culture of life the way
to have less abortion is to have a ton
of sex
ed in schools it's to have condoms
everywhere it's to get every girl on the
pill
it's to have people having casual sex
but where they're really focused in on
the
timing and the risks and okay so
those two things can't be true at the
same time you're shaking your head which
makes me think
you've got an answer on which one's
right well it's a as i said earlier it's
a feeder system and i mean i've been
investigating planned parenthood for
over 10 years now and it's absolutely a
theater system for abortion i mean there
is a reason that planned parenthood's
abortion rates have gone up over the
last 10 years
but the national abortion rates have
gone down so what this is what planned
parenthood does
they want to sexualize our kids they
want our kids to sexually experiment
they don't want
kids and young people to see sex as
something sacred
or connected to responsibility or
commitment they want to ultimately have
kids be sexually experimenting because
they know that contraception has a
failure rate
and that is i mean i mentioned earlier
the statistic 50
of women who have abortions were using
contraception the month they got
pregnant so
contraception every kind even
sterilization getting a vasectomy will
give you
a failure rate there's a failure right
there the only thing that has no failure
rate
for unplanned pregnancy is the
responsibility and the choice to say
i'm not ready to be a parent yet and i
respect you so much i'm not gonna have
sex with you unless we're gonna get
married and have a family together
i mean that's that's the ultimate uh
proper proper path and to say oh
kids you know planned parenthood line is
well that's not going to work because
kids
are kids and you know people are people
and they're just going to act on their
biological impulse
we're more than that we're more than
just our biological impulse we do have
the power to make decisions we do have
the power to
to have self-control and yes does that
mean mistakes are sometimes made yes
they are and i actually sure in my book
the story for our family i mean my
sister is one of my heroes my little
sister katarina
i had her ultrasound picture growing up
when i prayed to god for a little sister
on the
on the fridge and her she she shares her
story she allowed me to share a story
she's very open about it
she went through a really hard time she
struggled with things and a lot of i
talk about mental health challenges in
my book and
and her struggles there and then she
ends up having an unplanned pregnancy
and the pressures of friends not our
family thankfully but friends around her
that she should just she could just take
care of this you know that was that was
the message i mean they weren't telling
her when she was having sex and not
ready to be a mom
don't do that they when she gets
pregnant then it's go have an abortion
and she bravely chooses life it changes
her life
and you know my nephew this amazing kid
changes my sister's life transforms her
she ends up marrying the guy they have
their
they have another child now and her her
story is
um yes in a society mistakes are made i
mean
we're not trying to be prudes here about
step but the bottom line is this
what where are we directing people what
what is the moral code that we're
pointing to
and if there's no moral code and planned
parenthood is in the schools teaching
kids pornography masturbation sexual
deviancy
and now tran ideology i mean planned
parenthood is setting up shop with
hormones
in our communities to secretly give them
to little boys and girls a lot of
parents don't know this
but that's their new their new thing
their new gig um
that that's a culture of death right
there you're creating death cycles
for those people you're feeding the
abortion market
i love this idea we're not we're not the
prudes you know i think what
what the sexual revolutionaries want to
say is oh you fuddy-duddy conservatives
look
we're the world-wise uh radicals here
and we really know what's going on with
sex and i think hold on a second here
you're the people who say that uh casual
sex has no consequences and that
rampant abortion has no psychological
consequences and that the
contraception always works and that
little boys can become little girls
and you're accusing me of being ignorant
and naive actually maybe it's the
pro-lifers who have
who have a little bit more of a keen
sense
of how life really works we only have a
few minutes left
but i i would like you to address what
what i have found to be
the most honest argument for abortion
i've ever heard
this is from naomi wolfe naomi wolf is a
feminist she's actually seems to be
having some discipline changing
yeah she's changing before our very eyes
but she infamously said some years ago
she said look all this talk about how
abortion doesn't take a human life and
it's just a
zygote or a fetus or that's all bunk
that's ridiculous
yes abortion does take a human life
however
women and men are not the same women
have this disadvantage they got to deal
with something men don't have to deal
with
and so for there to be true equality
between the sexes
women need to be able to kill their
children in all their humanity
and she got a ton of blowback for it and
i i mean it was what she's saying is
ghastly
but i i felt the blowback was undeserved
because that woman unlike
virtually every other abortion supporter
i know was being honest about the stakes
so how's her argument wrong yeah there's
honesty to her argument in the sense
that
she's admitting the reality of the
humanity of those children and just
saying yes it does kill them and that's
okay that's my right
um but listen what is equality equality
is not
sameness if i had if i had the right as
a woman to be equal to every other man
then i have the right to have your same
strengths physically to have your same
attributes i mean equality is not safe
the fact that i can bring life into the
world and you can't michael doesn't mean
that we're not
equal in dignity thanks for rubbing it
in yeah
but it means that we're different and
that's good i'm glad we're different
you know i'm glad we're everyone's
different so what are
the differences are actually gifts and
to say that our ability to bring
children into the world means that we
have the ability to then kill them
it's like saying because a man has the
ability to be strong and and be
oppressive over another individual
that's physically weaker then he has the
right to somehow oppress that weaker
individual
we will all have the ability to be
stronger than others and have others
even dependent on us
but another person especially a child
our child
dependency biologically emotionally
um their weakness does not give us the
right to take their life
and i think that's the key the natural
place for a human life
to begin their life is in the body of
their mother that's how they start
that's how we all start our life
and so we should have a a profound
respect for that bond
and fight to support those mothers men
should be supporting those women
um if they're the father that should be
100 their focus is helping her and
helping that child
instead of saying because i'm i have
another human dependent on me i have the
right to conquer them and kill them
that's not morality that's not justice
well
said and you you've rubbed it in but you
make the point no one ever confuses me
for lila rose
nobody i try i do my hair up i try to
look nice
nobody nobody ever does you're great the
way you are
embrace your impress like my book know
your work
i will know my worth i will not try to
identify as other people uh i really
really strongly recommend
well one i mean just go follow lila well
where can people follow you on social
media
thank you so i'm all over wherever you
are on socials uh lila grace rose lila
rose official
on instagram on facebook and then it's
liveaction.org and live action's all
over so we're the leading
educational educational leader for the
public movement so check us out and get
equipped and then fighting for life is
anywhere you get your book so i hope
it's inspiring and helpful for you
there it is go get the book fighting for
life becoming a force for change
in a wounded world read the book do the
stuff
and help repair the world just a little
bit make it a little bit less wounded
lila
thank you so much for being here thanks
for having me michael
[Music]
you